derek was chosen among other reasons
because he had a clean cut so the edges
of the cup were quite close together
and the surrounding tissue was not
damaged the question was could we take
something from the area that will repair
itself the nose and Transplant it into
the spinal cord that doesn't repair
itself cells from the nose are the ones
that provide the pathway for our factory
nerves to grow no other nerves grow so
if we could take the cells from the nose
and Transplant them into areas where
their fathers don't grow they'll get in
the world and that's what worked I would
see this rolling out across the world
being carried out in neurosurgical units
and people no longer being confined to
wheelchairs in ten years